so welcome back everybody part two part
4 of the SOS Victorian part 2 of uncle
great so thanks for coming back so last
time we did extremely common Toric's and
I want to continue this theme of
explaining how SOS is related to other
disciplines we talked about extremal
combinatorics and this time we're gonna
roll up our sleeves and do quantum
mechanics but without bras and ket's so
actually the first thing I want to do is
I want to introduce a complimentary view
to what Pablo introduced in the first
two parts of this tutorial so there's
another way to think about SOS which is
actually very useful for both rounding
SOS getting algorithms out of it which
is something really interesting that all
sorts of people are working on and even
how to prove lower balance for things
like planted cleat so let me introduce
this dual view of SOS so this is what
we'll be using throughout this talk
which is called a pseudo expectation
it's something that masquerades as an
expectation but isn't it only has some
of the consistency checks so the way to
think about it let me just define it and
this is you know going to be a little
bit of a mouthful but such as life so
what's going to happen is we think about
an operator that takes any polynomial of
degree at most D in and variables and it
Maps it the some real value of course
the expectation is something that could
do that like if you think about some
distribution of values for your
variables x1 through xn then if you give
me a polynomial I could just compute the
expectation of that polynomial on those
that distribution of variables the
pseudo expectation is going to act like
that so it'll have many of the same
properties about an expectation so for
example a tilde is going to be linear
after all the expectation would be so if
you give me two polynomials P and Q and
I look at e to the P plus Q it better be
equal to e tilde of P plus au tilde of Q
fine
so the other thing is that you know if
you gave me the polynomial 1 and this
was a polynomial that you know is in
principle in variables x1 through xn
we're thinking about a distribution on
those variables being set but I ask you
what's the expectation of one that
better be one so e tilde of 1 is 1 now
this is the thing where all of the
action is really happening is whenever
you give me a polynomial P
and I look at the pseudo expectation of
its square that it better be
non-negative now this is only going to
make sense as long as the degree of the
polynomial is at most D over 2 because
the pseudo expectation operator is only
defined out to degree B polynomials so
this is also something that you know
it's certainly be true for the
expectation like again I give you a
distribution on values for x1 through xn
you give me a polynomial well you take
the square of that polynomial and
compute the expectation better get
something non-negative so these are the
general constraints you know this is
another view of s.o.s these are the
constraints that you impose on a pseudo
expectation operator regardless of what
problem you want to solve now there are
some specific constraints that you
impose depending on the particular
problem you care about so in general you
remember that the SOS is a relaxation
for a general polynomial optimization so
one of the things that you could have in
your polynomial optimization problem is
you could have an equality constraint
where you have some polynomial Q of X
and you want that Q of X is equal to 0
on all of the solutions you look at this
vector X is really X 1 up to xn so
that's some sort of constraint in your
polynomial optimization problem and the
way that this gets translated into some
sort of constraint in the pseudo
expectation is that you force that a
tilde of P times Q had better be equal
to 0 for all things which meet this
degree bound that you're only evaluating
it on degree up to D things so if you
want that any solution you find
satisfies this constraint Q of x equals
0 then the way that you impose that
within the pseudo expectation of U is
you just say that any polynomial P you
give me which the total degree inside
here is so that my pseudo expectation
operator is still define you want that a
tilde of P times Q had better be equal
to 0
and the last thing is I'm really just
gonna state these general constraints
but then we're gonna roll up our sleeves
and look at what they look like in
particular contacts the last type of
constraints you can think about for SOS
is you might have a constraint that for
all of your solutions you want Q of X is
non-negative and the way that this gets
translated into a constraint on your
pseudo expectation operator is that for
all polynomials P you want the pseudo
expectation of P squared times Q to be
non-negative so these are the problem
specific constraints
so this is the way that you write down
an SOS relaxation you take your favorite
polynomial optimization problem and then
what you do is instead of looking for
you know you relax it by instead of
looking for a solution you could look at
a distribution on solutions to your
optimization problem and then you relax
that even further because you could look
at something called the pseudo
distribution which satisfies all of
these constraints that the distribution
on solutions would satisfy but it only
satisfies these consistency checks up to
some degree so it's a higher and higher
level of self-consistency in this thing
that's trying to masquerade like a
distribution so this is you know a
mouthful anyway you look at it this is a
laundry list of constraints but this is
what you got to do every time you talk
about using SOS either for upper or
lower bounds now what I promised you is
I want to explain you know how SOS says
something about quantum and actually how
quantum information theory has a lot to
do with understanding the power of SOS
as you go to higher and higher levels in
your relaxation so that's what I'm going
to do the first thing is you know I'm
gonna prove I'm gonna kind of proof
result which you can state without
quantum about polynomial optimization
and the way that I'm going to do it is
illustrate a really important principle
within sum of squares so and the
principle I want to illustrate is that
let's see this
is really how to go about designing an
algorithm for some optimization problem
you care about via SOS this on the left
hand side is just how to mechanically go
through and create your relaxation your
convex program but one of the important
things is this principle which I'll
state now but we'll see what this means
throughout this talk is what you're
going to do is you're going to pretend
you actually have a distribution and you
fix your argument later so you take your
polynomial optimization problem you
write down this relaxation you solve it
and what you found from your convex
program is some eat ilton now that's not
a distribution on solutions but you're
just gonna pretend that it is a
distribution on solutions and if it was
you're going to figure out how to round
it to one solution and not a
distribution find one solution that
works and all of that will just be
probabilistic reasoning but at the end
of the day what you have is not a
distribution it's a pseudo distribution
and then you fix your argument later and
make it you know all of the steps in it
use just these basic properties that the
pseudo expectation operator satisfies in
how you did your rounding algorithm so
this is not made to make sense yet this
is just a roadmap of where we're going
and hopefully it'll make sense as we go
through the ideas so let me tell you a
really nice theorem which of roc Kellner
and story I'm gonna state the theorem
then I'll tell you how it relates to
quantum and then we'll give a proof
along these lines using this principle
so the idea is that you're given a
non-negative
symmetric matrix M which is now going to
be in our and squared by N squared well
there's a quasi-polynomial time there's
a end to the log n over epsilon squared
time algorithm to find a unit norm X in
Euclidean norm that has the following
property so X is a length n vector and
we're going to take X or X tensor with
itself so we get a length N squared
vector that's a unit vector and we're
gonna look at that length N squared
vector this quadratic form on M so
that's a problem we want to solve we
find an X which has the property that
it's close to the largest of any such
form so if you look at the max overall
unit vectors of Z tensor to quadratic
form on M that it's close to the max but
off by something which depends on the
spectral norm of M so this is a really
basic polynomial optimization problem
see the fact that you're taking X so X
tensor 2 is not an arbitrary length n
square unit vector after all then this
would be a really simple problem to
solve you just take the largest eigen
vector of the matrix but X is
constrained and that you you know the X
tensor 2 is constrained that it actually
has to be the tensor of some length n
vector with itself so this the way you
should think about it is it's really
like you know if you think about x1
through xn as being your original
variables it's like taking a degree 4
polynomial and then writing down the
coefficients of that degree 4 polynomial
into a matrix M that's N squared by N
squared and then this form right here
all it does it takes that degree 4
polynomial
and evaluates it on X so instead of
trying to maximize a quadratic function
you're trying to maximize something
which is a fourth order degree four
polynomial so that's a polynomial
optimization problem which you can
approximately optimally solve you can
get close to the maximum of that degree
four polynomial on unit vectors Z but
you're off by something that depends on
the spectral norm of the matrix and as
you decrease epsilon the running time of
your algorithm you know it goes up
pretty badly but you get a finer and
finer approximation to this polynomial
optimization problem so this was a
problem we're gonna solve through sum of
squares but actually the first thing I
want to do is I want to make good on
this promise of Y this is related to
quantum mechanics so we're gonna see two
relationships of this the quantum
mechanics so we'll do the first one for
the time being so you know why is this
related to quantum
so just like I don't do extremal
combinatorics but my last lecture was
about it I also don't do quantum so let
me give you an on quantum persons view
of quantum so let's do that so the first
important thing is the notion of a
quantum state so what is this so let's
define it so a quantum state row we'll
think of it as being on some vector
space CN well all it is is something row
lives actually in C n times n so it's an
N by n matrix it has the property that
it's PSD and it's Trace is equal to 1 so
there's this phrase you hear you this is
spectral so operator norm
Thanks so this is their notion of
quantum states so sometimes you hear
this expression that you know quantum
mechanics you can see probability
happening inside it if you've restrict
the diagonal matrices so if for the
moment you think about Rho as being a
diagonal matrix right so it has only
zeros on the off diagonal then if being
PSD just means that it's entry wise
non-negative along the diagonal and
trace one just means that it sums to 1
along the diagonal so it's really if you
look at the diagonal you get a
probability distribution on n now this
is just an extension which allows you to
you know work with arbitrary PSD
matrices that's what a quantum state is
but it has lots of amazing properties
like entanglement and things like this
but you know another equivalent way also
to think about it which is helpful to
keep in mind
is this set of densities so if I look at
the set of all densities that meet this
definition that's nothing more than the
convex hull of X X hermitian where
X has norm 1 and X here is a vector in C
n so one way to think about it is if I
took such an X which was a unit vector
in of length N and complex dimensional
space and I take it times its hermitian
then what I get is definitely PSD and
it's Trace as 1 because the trace of X X
permission is just the norm of X and in
fact you can take the convex hull if any
of those guys and still get a valid
quantum state and that's all the quantum
states there are it's just the convex
hull of all vectors of this form so now
let's get to something interesting which
is say quantum mechanics is funny there
are all sorts of you know entanglement
and cancellation and what-have-you
but there's a sense in which you can
make a quantum state behave classically
if you constrain it in some way so
that's the notion of a separable state
so this is the other key definition so a
state row again in this well now it's
going to be in a space so we think
instead of it being a n by n matrix it's
now an N squared by N squared matrix but
it's going to be separable if
it's actually in a simpler set so in the
convex hull of row 1 tensor Row 2 where
these guys are quantum states and their
own right this is the crucial definition
so why this is important
it's a restriction on the set of all you
know quantum states in this which are N
squared by N squared matrices you want
that you can represent it as a convex
combination of Row 1 and Row 2 which are
themselves valid quantum states and so
the way to think about this is that you
know that's the same thing as it being
in the convex hull of X X hermitian
tensor y y hermitian again with the you
know same thing that the norms of x and
y are one and these are lengths and
vectors so it's important about
separable States is that there's no
entanglement so a lot of times you have
to separate quantum systems and because
entanglement can create such funny
properties if you think about like
quantum to proofer games for those of
you know complexity theory a lot of
times the difficulty in understanding
whether a pair of players has a good
strategy is and controlling the types of
funny strategies that can come if they
do have entanglement so the name of the
game is to prevent them tangle meant and
to make the correlations between Row 1
and Row 2 just be purely classical
correlations and this is sort of an
important concept in in quantum and also
in quantum in from in quantum complexity
so just to understand how this
polynomial optimization problem relates
to this notion of separable States let's
figure it out so here's the relation
between the two
so let's say that M spectral norm is at
most one then a lot of times you can you
know what's really going on is that it's
a quantum test that measures some
quantum state and comes out with some
probabilities of various outcomes now if
the state is real you know real and
symmetric then what we're gonna get when
we look at how often you know if we look
at this maximization problem range then
solving in this theorem well that's the
same thing just using the standard trace
identities as M the trace of M times X
tensor 2 times X tensor to transpose
here I use transpose because it's its
real value so this right here is the
probability
that some test passes that it ends up
with some outcome in quantum mechanics
and so it turns out that when you view
things you know we can naturally want to
solve polynomial optimization problems
like the thing on the left hand side but
what that really relates that quantum
mechanics is for example figuring out
the probability that a separable state
passes some test so why is it separable
because I don't have an arbitrary PSD n
squared by N squared matrix here I have
one which is really X tensor 2 times X
tensor to transpose so why doesn't 0 0
plus 1 1 so this is one of the EPR pairs
yeah
that's not separable yeah so can I take
that off I mean that it's gonna take me
to bra and ket notation but no but I
promised I wouldn't so I can't sorry I'm
gonna have to take that one offline but
let's chat afterwards about why you know
maximally entangled state doesn't meet
these conditions but you know one way to
think about it is for example looking at
tests and seeing that you can express
the correlations between them as a
purely classical way in terms of the
correlations of the different subsystems
ok so you know I want to I'm gonna get
to this proof or at least you know how
to use this principle of pretending of a
distribution of fixing it later
but you know I do want to mention for
example that you know some of the types
of problems that people study within
quantum information theory so one really
nice result this was studied by Randall
sandal and yard and 11 was really a dual
problem which is a very natural question
which is if you're given some quantum
state which is not necessarily separable
well what you could want to do is you
can want to figure out how close the
separable it is so in that sense what
you want to do is you want to find some
test M that maximizes trace of M row
minus the max over all row prime that
are separable of the trace of M row
Prime so you can think about it you know
if I give you a state row you want to
figure out whether this state is
separable that's a very natural goal
with in quantum and one way to try and
figure out if it is or isn't separable
or how far it's away from being
separable is to try and find a test that
distinguishes it from the set of
separable States this is some convex
body that's hard to characterize it's
something that's very unwieldy to
express in terms of sum of squares and
we'll see that later so if for example
your row really was separable then you
know finding this test you're always
going to get 0 you're never gonna have a
test that actually distinguishes it from
separable but if for example you have a
row that's far from separable being able
to approximately solve this maximization
problem a finding a test M where this
quantity is as large as possible it's a
certificate that your state is far from
separable so the same way that you know
you can solve polynomial optimization in
quasi-polynomial time what Brando at all
were doing was they were using the same
types of SOS tools to approximately
solve these types of problems up to some
additive epsilon that depends on the
spectral norm of them and that's really
like being able to approximately decide
whether you're given state row is close
to the set of separable stay
it's in some norm that depends on for
example how you constrain it so this
stuff gets a little bit unwieldy because
very quickly you know we're used to like
spectral norms and trace norms but
there's something called the one-way LOC
C norm which is how they proved it and
it's a very complicated norm that
requires a lot of quantum to define but
this is roughly the spirit of these
types of results is polynomial
optimization also relates to this
quantum problem of given some norm
figuring out how close your state row is
to being separable or not and they're
also quasi-polynomial time algorithms
that work based on the same types of SOS
technology all right so this was enough
of a digression about quantum and I'm
going to come back to quantum later but
now I want to tell you you know how this
proof works and how this principle can
be applied because it sounds very
mysterious right now
I only know of the yeah I'm not sure
whether it's actually extended I think
the brandão at all result works for
quantum but don't quote me on that but
take that offline okay so now I want to
illustrate this principle let's go
through this proof of this theorem and
use this principle of let's pretend we
have a real distribution on our
solutions to our polynomial optimization
problem and we're gonna fix the argument
later so let's prove I'll put it tilde
because it's a pseudo proof this result
okay so the idea is that we start off
with you know suppose we're given
distribution on unit vectors
which achieve value yeah okay so what
this means is that you know someone's
going to give you access to a
distribution on the vectors X so that
the expectation remember M is really a
degree four polynomial so the
expectation of P of X when you take X
from that distribution is at least gamma
so someone gave you a distribution on
unit vectors that makes the for degree
four polynomial have expected value at
least gamma now one question we could
ask is you know how do we actually find
a solution that actually achieves good
values you know all we have access to is
the distribution and we want to use
access only to the distribution to
figure out how to round it to a single
good solution for the polynomial so
here's the idea we want to try and find
a single unit factor
we've value close to that now just like
we had this additive epsilon
approximation to our polynomial
optimization problem we have the same
relaxation here you give me a
distribution on solutions with expected
value gamma all I'm gonna ask you is to
produce one unit vector that achieves
value at least gamma minus Epsilon
so here's the idea let's just write down
and just for simplicity I'm going to
normalize things so let's say that M has
unit spectral norm now the idea is let's
translate what we have so D is our
distribution on solutions and we have
the property that some over ijkl of M
ijkl X I XJ XK XL is at least gamma
someone gave me the distribution whose
expected value on the polynomial is at
least gamma so there's a natural way to
try and round this into just a single
vector so let's try to follow we're
gonna let X star it's going to be a unit
vector where of length n where the eyuth
coordinate is equal to square root of
the expectation of d of x i squared so
someone gives me the distribution and
I'm allowed to evaluate moments or
expectations of polynomials one way to
turn that into a unit vector is just to
do the simple translation you give me
access to the expectation of the
distribution I compute this value for
each coordinate I and the first claim is
that this really is a unit vector
this is really simple what do we do well
we just compute its norm so we look at
the sum of squares for this guy and
that's the same thing just using the
definition of the expectation over d of
x i squared now we bring in the sum
inside so it's the expectation over D of
the sum over I of X I squared that's
just the definition but the key point is
that this distribution is only a
distribution on unit vectors so this
quantity in here is always 1 if it
really worried distribution on unit
vectors so this is just some way of
taking our distribution on solutions and
doing something coordinate wise to try
and find a guess x star which hopefully
solves our optimization problem of
finding one particular solution that
makes this degree four polynomial be
large the trouble is that this doesn't
always work otherwise we could call it a
day pretty easily so let's understand
what can go wrong and how we can fix
what's going wrong
the difference the point is you're not
allowed to sample for the distribution
agent still have to evaluate test yes
exactly
so the way I've asked this question it
sounds kind of trivial someone gave me a
distribution that does all of the hard
work right it could just sample from it
and take a typical vector but here I'm
only going to be able to compute moments
to find my guess why because the reality
is when I remove this tilde and I
actually want to prove it I'll have to
move the tilde everywhere here and I
only have sudo expectations so you can't
sample from a pseudo expectation because
it's honestly not an expectation there
is no distribution that meets those
conditions so if we can do something
using this framework where we don't
actually sample from the distribution
then we can actually translate this to
an actual proof that goes from the
pseudo expectation to an actual vector
but thanks for that point all right so
let's do this so let's understand if
it's objective value is much smaller so
let's imagine that it's too small for
our purposes so imagine we take this X
star and we plug it in to our polynomial
optimization problem so we take its
tensor with itself and we look at its
quadratic form on the matrix M so what
if it's too small it's actually gamma
minus epsilon so no good we're gonna
have to figure out some other way to
find our unit vector but the idea is the
following is we're going to define some
notion of making progress on this
distribution how we're actually
simplifying it to a lower entropy
distribution every time this type of
condition happens so I'm going to
consider one other vector so I'm going
to let Y be the N squared dimensional
vector
it's a unit vector for the same reasons
where y IJ is the square root of the
expectation of D of X I squared X J
squared so Y is a length N squared
dimensional vector and here's you know
the same way that I computed X star just
from the individual moments I can create
Y through pairwise moments using this
type of property but the crucial point
is that the same way that rounding to X
star could have made our solution worse
it turns out that rambling to Y only
makes our solution value larger it's
just not a valid solution to our
original optimization problem because no
one tells me that Y is actually the
tensor of two unit vectors so let's
prove that you know if X star is smaller
you know Y star Y is larger and then
we'll understand you know what's going
wrong when we have too small an
objective value so what I claim is the
following
well gamma is by definition j KL m IJ K
L the expectation over D of X I XJ XK
and X L right
I guess less than or equal to so now we
can do is we can just apply Cowie
Schwarz so Cowie Schwartz tells us that
this is less than or equal to M IJ K L
square root times the expectation over D
of X I squared X J squared
as the same thing for K&L
so the way to think about this is you
could you know em by definition up by
sumption is non-negative you could just
think about em is just being all ones
for simplicity to see why this follows
from kouchi schwartz and then you're
just applying it on the resulting you
know constituent vectors i'm bracketing
these two together and considering them
as a vector you know over my
realizations of my distribution i get
this out for its to norm and i bracket
these two and consider it as a vector
over the realization of my distribution
i get this guy but now we're in business
because this guy right here is just y IJ
that's how we defined it and this guy
right here is y KL so what this means is
that at the end of the day we found some
vector Y which is not a valid solution
because Y is not the tensor of a unit
vector with itself but we have found a y
which makes the objective value on M at
least as large as the expectation whats
so now we want to understand what's
happened when X star the individual
coordinate wise rounding is very
different an objective value then the
pairwise rounding which we get for y so
what does it mean that this value is at
least gamma but this value is at most
gamma minus epsilon it turns out there's
a sense in which what that means is that
there is there's an underlying
distribution where we can look at
entropy of that the you know the the two
coordinates how much one tells us about
the other and it's really saying the
only way that we can have this objective
be larger than this one is if there is
information going on in the correlations
between these coordinates so we'll find
a way of reducing that amount of mutual
information to try and make progress
towards finding a unit vector so let me
explain what this means now the state of
affairs and we have X star doesn't work
but Y is certainly at least as large
[Music]
all right so putting it all together we
know that epsilon is a lower bound on
the difference between these two
quadratic forms one we get from Y and
the other we get from X star that's just
the situation we're in so now we can
write this out in another way which we
can write it as a quadratic form one
right subtract Y from X star tensor with
itself and the other one where I add the
two it's just
elementary algebra so this guy right
here I'm just gonna upper bound that's
you know these two guys are unit vectors
so the sum of them has not too large
norm so let me just create a really
loose upper bound and remember by
assumption we had that m's operator norm
was at most one we fixed that
normalization so at the end of the day
what this means is that we have the
following upper bound on this quadratic
form is it's at most the difference
between y and x star 10 surd with itself
that quantity is at least epsilon so
let's translate what this means so what
I claim is that this quantity right here
can be interpreted
information theoretically so let's just
try and understand what's going on here
so the way that this is going to work is
we're gonna consider two random
variables W and W prime which are both
distributions over some set in by n so
each random variable just tells me an
index from 1 to N and another index from
1 to n all right and what these random
variables are let's define them in terms
of x star and Y so I'm gonna set the
probability that this random variable W
is equal to the pair IJ those are just
two indices from 1 to n that I'm going
to let it be the expectation over D of X
I squared X J squared that's some
quantity so why is this a probability
it's just because the sum over all IJ if
this guy is 1 so this takes my unit
vector and define some probability
distribution associated with it and the
same way I'm going to define the
probability of W prime is equal to IJ is
the pair of independent random variables
so what I promised you was I wanted to
define two random variables W and W
prime which are both two different
distributions of her pairs of indices
from 1 to N the way that the random
variables are defined is through these
identities W is the random variable
which on a pair IJ has this probability
of being IJ and W prime is the one that
has this probability now these are
distributions just because the fact that
Y and X star are both unit vectors now
the important thing is W prime I and J
are independent of each other literally
it's the product of two probabilities
it's the same random variable we would
get by choosing the index I according to
these values X I squared and choosing J
according to these values XJ squared
whereas this one actually incorporates
the pairwise relationship between the
indices these are playing the roles of Y
and X star respectively so my claim is
that this quantity the fact that Y and X
star tensor 2 is at least Epsilon this
turns out to actually be this is related
to the Hellinger distance in information
theory so if we look at the two random
variables the coordinate I in the
coordinate J the only way that we can
have these two differences the one that
we get by looking at pairwise moments on
the ones we get by doing things
independently be noticeably different is
if there is some information in
correlation between I and J so that's
the idea is that the only way that Y
could have had a larger quadratic form
than what X star gets is if there's some
correlation between these two
coordinates so now the idea is the
following say this
so if we let capital W be w1 w2 so this
is the random variable so what this
means is that Y minus X star tensor 2
has Euclidean norm at least epsilon over
2 turns out that tells you that the
mutual information between the random
variables W 1 and W 2 is at least
something depending on Epsilon that's
the sort of key idea is that see if we
had the mutual information between these
two variables W 1 and W 2 being 0 then
actually the distributions W and W prime
would get out are the same because the
only way that the mutual information
between the two coordinates is 0 is if
they're actually independent which means
that we get exactly the same expression
here so the fact that W and W prime
which give you Y and X star respectively
for the unit vectors that they're
associated with give you different
objective values just means that these
two random variables aren't that close
to being independent so you know that
there actually is mutual information
between them so now here's the idea so
mutual information between W 1 and W 2
you can define it in many different ways
but you can look at the loss in entropy
so for example if w1 and w2 are the same
random variable then when I condition on
W - I have no more entropy left in w1 so
my mutual information is exactly the
entropy of w1 so it's the idea is how
much one coordinate tells you about the
other the completely equivalent way to
define it is with H of W 2 minus H of W
2 conditioned on W 1 so it's really
telling you that you know when I fix W 2
how much of the randomness have I taken
out of W 1 so the sort of key takeaway
is that the only way that we have a
difference between jected value between
X star and Y is if fixing one of the
coordinates tells me a lot about the
other but that's going to be our
progress measure is when you encounter
the situation where you're naive
rounding X star doesn't work what you're
going to do is you're gonna tell me one
of the coordinates and that's going to
reduce the amount of entropy in the
other coordinate so that I get closer
and closer to being not a distribution
and actually having one solution for my
optimization problem yep
whereas it not yeah so okay so this is
this is a Hellinger distance so you
really have to use the relationship
between Hellinger and mutual information
and KL divergence and honestly I didn't
feel like looking up what the right
constant was so I put 8 so it's
definitely 8 at least but you could
optimize that no yeah I mean so it's
when you do pin scores in equality so
you really have to use you know the
version of Hellinger that relates it to
TV and KL divergence and then there are
some constants the same way that there
are constants and Pinsker so I wrote the
eight just for slack any other questions
all right so let's do this
so just the trans like this what this
means is that you know what this mutual
information means if we condition on w-2
then the entropy of w1 drops by at least
epsilon squared over 8 that's exactly
what this relationship means as we start
off with this random variable w1 and the
only way that they have mutual
information between w1 and w2 is if when
we condition on w2 we actually reduce
the entropy of the new random variable W
1 conditioned on w2 let's see what I
claim is that the entropy of w1 couldn't
have been that large to begin with so w1
is a distribution on n different things
so the entropy at the beginning is it
most log in you know whenever you have a
random variable the maximum entropy
distribution for it is just uniform on
the domain which is entropy log in so
what this means is we're making progress
we started off with something which had
entropy log N and we tried this naive
rounding or we constructed X star but X
star might not work the only way that X
star doesn't work is if there's some
mutual information between the
coordinates and when we condition on one
of the coordinates that reduces the
remaining entropy on the first one so
we're making progress towards it so this
is exactly where this quasi-polynomial
comes in from these polynomial
optimization problems is that entropy is
your underlying potential function you
start off with it most log n bits of
entropy and every time you're reducing
the entropy where you don't find an
actual solution by at least epsilon
squared that's why their running time of
these polynomial optimization problems
and the things from quantum information
theory depends exponentially on log n
over epsilon squared it comes from this
sort of potential function so let me
really tell you the idea now but the
idea is that just summarizing everything
together so either X star this naive
rounding works meaning that it achieves
value at least gamma minus Epsilon
or we can condition on J and get a new
distribution
where the entropy is dropped
let me just translate this into what
this really means so what this means is
in the situation here where you really
need to make progress what you do is you
choose I according to the following
distribution remember I is just the
distribution on one through n so the
probability you choose coordinate 1 is
just X 1 squared probability choose
coordinate 2 as the expectation of X 2
squared and so on all the way out to xn
squared so this is a probability
distribution you choose the coordinate I
according to this distribution and then
what you do is you choose J according to
the new marginal distribution
so you got to normalize it you know I
chose some X I so I need to normalize it
by whatever that probability was of
making that choice but the new vector
that I use to construct my next sample
XJ is I take X I squared and look at X 1
squared that's the probability that's
proportional probability my next choice
for J is 1 and then I do the same thing
for all of the other coordinates and so
on all the way out to xn squared so the
point is you can prove the same way
using the same types of identities we
already had that this is also a
distribution so all this is literally
doing is it's taking the distribution W
and it's marginally choosing what I is
and then choosing J according to the
correct conditional distribution see
instead of J being independent like it
is in W prime it now depends on what my
choice of I was so there are some pairs
which you have a larger probability this
is a different distribution for every
different on so the idea is that this
you can now use the simplify your
distribution so if hypothetically
someone gave you a distribution on
solutions and they gave you access to
some very high moments of the
distribution you either start off with X
star that works for your rounding
algorithm or if it doesn't work you're
gonna make one of the choices you know
for I and you're gonna look at the new
distribution you get out from it that
new distribution on solutions is the way
you generate your next guess for X star
and you try that guy out and you keep
doing this for log n over epsilon
squared rounds that many moments of
conditioning and the point is I can't
keep encountering this problem where you
know X star didn't work but why did
because eventually I'm going to run out
of entropy so that's the idea behind the
proof this is the sort of principle you
know a lot of these things in SOS get
pretty technical so this is a sort of
hand wavy way to do it which it
illustrates this principle that the way
that you try and round a pseudo
expectation it's always you think of it
as a distribution on
honestly solutions but you're only
allowed some limited interaction with
that distribution you can't just sample
from the distribution instead you have
to figure out how to round it just using
its moments you do it by cheating by
pretending it actually is a distribution
and proving that you find a good
solution in a small number of steps and
then you make all of these different
inequalities work even if there were
pseudo distributions and not
distributions so you literally have to
check that all of the different steps
that you use in here be it be they
things like Cowie Schwartz for example
the way that we use causa Schwartz here
are things that actually can be
implemented within the sum of squares
proof system and so they work not just
for distributions but even for pseudo
distributions and this is how polynomial
optimization works for these types of
things
I used it right here in that cow shorts
so if em weren't non negative then I
couldn't do this step because for
example even if I've one negative
coordinate game is over yeah so that's a
very good question so see what you
really need is that when I condition on
here
I want that the resulting distribution I
get is also a good solution to my
polynomial optimization problem so in
fact the you know the SOS the way that
you write it is that not only is the
original solution good in terms of
maximizing it and it meets all these PSD
nice constraints but for every choice of
you know I the new distribution I get
out X star which depends on the choice
that I will also be a good solution and
for every choice of inj it'll also be a
good solution I do that for log n you
know lengths and that you know still has
a feasible solution because the actual
solution which is just one value and as
a distribution supported on that one
evaluation has the property that when
you condition on I in this way you don't
actually change the solution that's
right that's right
yeah you I mean in all these things the
rounding algorithms only ever end up
using a subset of the actual
inequalities so one sort of interesting
direction which you know I'm not really
going to get into there's a lot of times
once you have these rounding algorithms
you can look at what actual things
you're using in the proof and sometimes
get faster algorithm so this is like
this work on speeding up some of squares
that sometimes you can even get the
power out of higher order SOS
relaxations without actually going up to
that degree a matrix polynomial yeah
that's right that's right
so this is um so this is for example you
know you can instead work with Hellinger
directly which instead of actually
translating it to how much the entropy
is lost there's a way just to do it
natively within the Hellinger distance
which is defined in terms of the
Euclidean distance between ym you know X
star tensor - so the difference between
a pairwise distribution and the product
of its two independent marginals well
that's a great question that happens all
when you try to remove the tilde in my
pseudo proof I don't know of how to
prove that but that's not what you end
up using to sort of make this go through
exactly so the point is the way that I
defined X star it only depended on these
guys right here so the way that when I
condition on I I define my new X star as
with this vector if I take the entry Y
square root of this guy you know with
the right normalization that will also
be a unit vector because this is a
distribution and that's my new one but I
might have to go even further out if the
next one doesn't work but then for the
J's actually I download a minus one
exactly yep exactly
yep yeah okay so I do want to say one
more thing and then we can do more
questions so I guess I don't have time
to talk about this but it turns out
there's this interesting relation
between this and quantum definitey
theorems so definite either ins are the
setting where what you have in the
classical setting is you have variables
x1 through xn which are what are called
exchangeable
and what that means is that when I take
a permutation of any of these variables
I get the same resulting distribution so
one natural way to get exchangeability
is by having these variables X I'd be
iid that would certainly be an
exchangeable thing but it's not the only
way because one thing that I can do is I
can for example take some variable theta
let's say to be uniform on the interval
0 1 and then each X I could be a
Bernoulli random variable with this
common probability theta so these now
are actually exchangeable but they're
not actually iid because once I realize
X 1 that tells me something about theta
but it's still true that every
permutation is the same so what ends up
happening is that when you have high
exchange ability this is the only thing
that can happen you're actually close to
being conditionally independent random
variables so what's actually going on
here is that the solution in the pseudo
expectation is actually a quantum state
that has a lot of symmetries it's
quantumly exchangeable meaning that any
of the subsystems that you get out in
different permutations are exactly the
same the same way that in classical
Definity you control how close you are
to being conditionally independent the
notion of conditionally dependent in
quantum is actually being close to
separable so it turns out that you know
this polynomial optimization problem
that we wanted to solve was related to
finding the best agreement in a
separable state but what we're really
doing is we're consumer constructing a
highly symmetric composite state so how
high order is that it depends on the
degree of the pseudo expectation but the
fact that you know it's exchangeable
that it's so highly symmetric is really
the thing that's happening in this
rounding algorithm it's saying that you
know the distribution I get first was
the same as the every distribution I get
by conditioning on I and so on and
that's the quantum notion of
exchangeability
which tells you that you're close to
being a separable state and that you're
close to being the optimizer to a
polynomial optimization problem so
there's a you know a lot of very
interesting work on you know how to
relate this that quantum Definity
theorems where you know
that's neat as there are information
theoretic ways through mutual
information to prove classical Definity
theorems but in quantum you use
something called the monogamy of
entanglement so now that I've gone half
way through what I wanted to get to I
think we'll stop there and part five and
six will be tomorrow so all right so
thanks and any questions you guys have
be happy to answer you know login
entropy is like the worst case to then
if you're really it would be I don't
know about that so so for example how
could I have log in entropy for my
marginal distribution on I my equals J
and it's random from 1 to N so that's a
case where actually my entropy starting
off for H of W 1 is actually log in
because it's uniform that's right that's
right yeah yeah yep yep yeah exactly
you're right but if you look at pairwise
you know the entropy of W 1 comma W 2
then you know that is maximum and it's
to log in and not log in then you really
are you know exactly independent but
some of this is funny because the other
thing is that there are many ways of
defining what independent random
variables are you know I could say that
I and J are independent if and only if
their mutual information is 0 that's
true
but there are many equivalent ways
through other information theoretic
notions of defining what independence
means I could also define it through
Hellinger as in you know the Euclidean
norm of this guy is zero but some are
more and less quantitative when you
relax that in the sense that if I'm only
have mutual information epsilon or
epsilon squared how close am I to being
independent so that's you know a little
bit technical but that's one of the
issues is that it depends on how you
measure independence and how it works
and you add soft constraints to
but also one of the subtleties which I'm
far from being an expert in is all these
quantum results they depend a lot on the
norm so when you look for an EM that you
want you know have maximally distinguish
your state from the set of separable
states it depends on what types of
constraints you impose on em you get all
sorts of different norms so by no means
are like quantum defend any theorems
which are related to this really
exhaustively understood because when you
strengthen the norm is it possible to
get you know good balance for how close
you are to being separable and what are
the best possible rates there's you know
lots and lots of papers on this exactly
that's exactly right exactly
yep so the video is the solution here
was you know getting this vector is just
expressible linearly or polynomial in
terms of the moments generally in this
framework do you need to be able to do
that where you express a teeny area for
nonlinear you can just use the moments
in any way well so one thing is that you
know if I had some other way of going
from my distribution to my candidate
solution as a way to round this you know
it could be that if that function is a
bit more complex than this linear or
polynomial if I then use Cowie Schwarz
who's to say whether you know I can
definitely do kouchi Schwartz on the new
vector but whether that translates into
constraints in the pseudo expectation it
depends on what function you choose for
it so that's it exactly so that's a
little bit tricky
like it's not formulaic for how to do
this but and by no means does everything
that pretends it's a distribution and
then rounds it necessarily give you an
actual algorithm you have to be careful
in which inequalities you're using and
that all of those inequalities really do
have a realization in terms of you know
either proof complexity how to you know
prove them using sum of squares or how
to derive them from the pseudo
expectation properties
which inequalities do actually use in
the food yeah you can basically do
everything of this work to do it
so kouchi Schwartz is definitely one of
the most powerful for you know most of
the rounding algorithms
you know the algorithms that come out of
SOS use kouchi Schwartz but there's also
something called PPT symmetries which
are really important that you know there
are other things which we're in my notes
which I don't have time to talk about
where for example you're talking about
refuting random three CSPs so when
you're talking about refuting
second-order CSP is like random to
sadder to X or you can turn that into a
matrix problem where eigen value bounds
on random matrices give you certificates
that the CSP is unsatisfiable when you
work with odd order things one of the
standard tricks us to use resolution to
turn it into an even order thing so for
example you could take two clauses which
are on three variables and do resolution
and create one clause on four variables
but those types of things when you then
try and turn that into random matrix
there it's a dependent random matrix
theory and it can be really sensitive to
how you index it like if I take you know
a pair of clauses you know I on
variables ijk and something else that
shares it you know I prime J Prime and K
Prime and I do resolution for example in
XOR and create some clause on IJ i prime
and J Prime how I map this into a matrix
of N squared by N squared it actually
completely changes what spectral bounds
you can prove whether you use this pair
to index the row or this pair index the
row the fact that they came from the
same constraints means that you don't
get good spectral nouns so they're also
what are called like PPT symmetries that
are very useful in conjunction with
Cowie Schwartz
[Applause]
[Music]